I've been doing work providing surgeries
for the poor in developing countries for
the past 25 years I've been to some of
the most wretched places on earth from
Afghanistan to Haiti to Bangladesh to
Uganda and I've seen so much suffering
and so much misery but I've never seen
anything as powerful is watching someone
who is blind open their eyes and see
today in 2015 there are 20 million
children and adults who were blind
solely because they can't afford a
surgery that takes as little as five
minutes and costs as little as $35
America spends 30 billion dollars every
year on AIDS malaria TB polio we just
spend tens of billions every year and we
seem to make very little progress it's
just so frustrating so when something
comes along that's correctable why don't
we solve it there are a lot of different
theories on this one of them is from his
brilliant Fulbright Scholar who coined
the term the tragedy of easy problems
and the idea is that the global health
folks and the big huge foundations
prefer to chase the famous or exotic or
sexy problems like AIDS or they want to
invent a miracle vaccine they don't want
to solve diarrhea which is an old
mundane problem but it kills millions of
children every year they don't want to
do cataract surgeries which were
perfected in 1949 because it's old news
and you're not going to win the Nobel
Prize for doing cataract surgeries or
cleft surgeries so a lot of the energy
and the money is chasing homeruns in
these huge problems that are very
difficult to solve and will take
billions and billions of dollars and
none of the attention goes to these
mundane problems if I was in charge of
our global health I would make a list of
the biggest problems starting from the
biggest to the smallest quote and then I
would have a column and it would have a
check in it existing cure solution or no
existing cure solution and then I would
go down and all the ones that have cure
is like cataract blindness
and burns and clubfoot and class and I'd
solved them first we could save and
change a lot of lives by spending just
even a little bit of money in that area